[Music]
personality over looks new
this is tiny this one's from your show
submitted by wonton soup I love one time
soup it's really good that's like
dumpling soup ha yeah well they fold it
a certain way they put stuff in line
it's different from the way they fold
dumplings that's for sure it's also
different the amount that you get per
place that you order I know why is it
only like one yeah we're a whole
bulletin no job because their laundry
money today a 21 year old amputee
receives 12 marriage proposals because
of her tinder profile what are the China
stage amputees can't get regulars
reportable [ __ ] up no girls get
marriage proposals all the time every
day dude and don't you who wrote the
article and wrote this article when you
check your D ABS don't you get a
marriage proposal every day and dick
pics I don't check yeah that's what
happens in girls instagrams proposals
and dick pics and guys don't care if
rules even have arms we really know yeah
yeah you do know what's gonna [ __ ]
give you a [ __ ] I don't want him to
ever thank you I saw this picture of a
girl that was really beautiful and she
didn't have an arm and then the meme was
I bet you didn't notice she didn't have
an arm and I was like yep yeah because
that's how guys are
yeah I could I mean if it is hot enough
and she has no arms and no legs I can
make it work yep yeah sure you know I
have full full function ya know I'm fine
with it because when I do this mr. no
I'm Hawking night I already got I'm good
with you but I'm just saying I could
have made that work you could have
amount to make the past ten four hours
because you can't [ __ ] legs you can't
really talk hands burn so I guess like
legs well you know you know one thing a
guy can't [ __ ] with legs now we can if
he's not creative probably well I know
you're talking about anger you go suck a
hand no you can [ __ ] hand but it's
something great right I'm talking about
yeah it's not that great you should say
how you can make it work yeah I can make
it work of course you can make it
anything you want to [ __ ] is [ __ ] and
just like she's that [ __ ] then that's
how you make a wish it's not hot enough
but it's not because you don't want to
ugly ass girl with no arms and no legs
then you can't make it work I'm still
glad you're here because I feel like I'm
currently translating for me
yeah anyways this woman shut up my name
is Lauren she's 21 years old from San
Diego and she lost her arm a year ago in
a moped accident oh man
but recently she's been going viral
because someone found her tinder profile
micellar looks nice
thank she's hot yeah she's really hot
okay she keeps she's arms dealers yeah
so it's like her her job is an arms
dealer she's joking right hand down the
best catch on tinder face ten out of ten
body and nine out of ten personality
twenty out of ten arms one attitude and
she knows how to have fun are Kiedis
yeah I think that is a attractive though
yeah she's hot I mean there's girls with
all limbs that are way [ __ ] uglier
than she is oh yeah and she's not ugly
I'm just saying the girls out there to
have all limbs but nobody will [ __ ] them
somebody'll [ __ ] them you're right
you're right sorry somebody else but
they won't love them I agree yes yes I'm
gonna play a little clip of hers I don't
even notice the arm it's good at stretch
low enough I mean you definitely notice
this much but you know but my eyes keep
going back and forth to the bay boobs
are away artists it's like it's a
triangle it's like a rumor luminaries
happening right here totally Jenner like
a what actual natural dye eye movement
just wasn't triangles like this really
conscious triangle guys it's like
[ __ ] pinball dude yeah I was going
bouncing around like alright here we go
hands down I am the best catch on tinder
there's no denying it this amputee is
that sensation on the popular dating app
can there's narrating life don't look at
needing a donut only doing it didn't
stop her from creating a profile that
puts her amputation now say why should I
stop with the cheeky bio my profession
is an arms dealer she also jokingly
writes
she's hands down the best catch on
tinder he got it after now inundated
with date requests I want to marry her
right now
goes one admirer Lawrence even had 12
proposals
got a lot of compliments now Lauren is a
mini celebrity around San Diego my
sister and I were at a restaurant and
the waitress is like oh my god you're so
brave even tinder is that might have
nothing to do with fund me page though
tenders money for a prosthetic arm they
donated $15,000 tenders honey disgusting
Wow
that does for her terrific sandwich
isn't one there are mine now yeah he
started to go timing Oh Sarah I want to
me they can make jokes I wonder if she's
going to go robotic or like fake humans
you want the robotics I do too that's
time yeah it's a Bionic Woman yeah so
she's already raised more than thirty
thousand dollars and her goal of $50,000
for a robotic online school yeah issues
of expenses she's always joking about
her missing arm I haven't heard that
name in years
the other one age actually I was in the
ocean in this little kids like what
happened to your arm and I told them it
was a shark and you ran out and has yet
to get back here I don't use the
clapping emoji because I can't clap and
I'm being completely honest yeah so he
was just fell in love with her
personality that's dope
a little ruthless you can clap why is
that RIT a little bit you could look
like smack attire yeah talking people to
quit dip like when I'm at a ballgame you
know I mean you got a hot dog he do some
of that
oh yeah yeah that's a finger do that
yeah nikki has an uncle who has one hand
yeah but she didn't tell me
cuz I did I don't see him so she didn't
tell me that he has one freaking hand
where I cut off that either wrist hell
yeah well I'll tell you what I ain't so
bad because as soon as I see the cast
but he's not a beautiful woman right I'm
just like wait what happened it's just
enough yeah it was like I don't even
think about that [ __ ] right we need you
so well no I shook his left hand
I did the left I did like oh yeah and
then the whole time just thinking about
it
what happened you friggin on today yeah
cuz it's cut up like race yes and it's
cut off it doesn't look like you was
like born this way or whatever it looks
like a machete just went it's like
something went down yeah well shed so
I'm like like as soon as we leave I'm
like I'm like what happened was on why
wouldn't you tell me and it took me a
second as like wait what do you mean
something happened
I mean it's been like that since I was
born like so because it happened to him
when he was 16 and so like I guess just
my Uncle Bob like I in the arm Lusaka
Heidi arm I don't my water honey miss
too bad I said that earlier
my dad was missing a pinkie and I never
realized it until other people started
pointing it out oh yeah you miss missing
a pinkie yeah Wow not funny it's just a
pinkie your hugs you know arm yeah but
that's weird but he's a part of the
Yakuza my dad's a forefinger freak oh he
cut yet his finger off because he joined
the gang I really did think I could do
oh that's what it is whatever you guys
are you were gonna game oh no he was I
so he had his own construction company
and then one of his workers just sliced
it off on accident yeah but look at the
work then yeah they work together or
there's 12 times after is that cool
that's crazy
we got even burn on purpose that's my
uncle Bobby's through the shark joke
because they live in Long Beach so we go
to the beach and he's like oh my god I
didn't know you worked at a dairy farm
and there was a conveyor belt oh my god
and no the room that got stuck and he
like went to grab it out it was just
like to God and was sad as though he
after his hand got chopped off he went
back to work no he like started running
it with you alone so we started running
down the street like like help and
people were like scared
so like nobody helps him for a while he
was alone in the factory yeah he
couldn't down I won one yeah you know
that was down here with the bloody nub
someone's drinking pink milk you're
running away from that person the truth
if someone's running down the street
with a with a bloody mob and yelling
even if
now Kerry wait let me help you I'm going
oh boy and I'm like who's after him yeah
who's coming around the corner we've got
to act like what's a boy my shoes like
oh you must work at the machine
processing plant yeah for some [ __ ] pink
milk
yeah there's pink milk somewhere out
there today guys right if I was that
shit's not strawberry either you know
the coconut waters that are a little bit
pink and they're like coconut water is
pink naturally milk is people actually
yeah that could be I don't know for me
I'm like maybe because I'm a guy and I
understand guys having no arm has
nothing to do with her ability to date I
don't know girl thing oh my god it's so
tragic if that happened to me like I
would never be able to go outside a date
again yeah I guess that's why she's
getting so much attention because
usually people want to hide whatever
happened to them and so she just worries
it probably she wear spaghetti strap I
think what Joe is saying is dependent on
the perspective of who's writers article
because for guys it's no [ __ ] yeah yeah
most guys don't see her to be like yeah
you should see a surprise for a girl's
no I don't think it's most guys I think
you guys are just a rare breed why cuz
you think guys would look at that go oh
I would never touch her no way I'm
pretty sure they're we're not even the
same breed just as you know we look
different from different places it's not
come we're not all the things like a
metrosexual dude would care that I
better not have an unarmed I feel like a
lot of guys he doesn't want to go get
the groceries or whatever yeah like that
kind of guy more like a function being
not aesthetic yeah I don't think it's
something nowadays what arms you can't
carry my bags for me right exactly
that's that's not yeah I don't think
it's a rare breed that's true
what would be a deal-breaker for you
deal-breaker yeah is like your vagina
was sealed shut some huh that does exist
though yeah I know that's a deal-breaker
I'm like I'm so sorry of that condition
is terrible oh that's sorry I don't
think well she I mean ship she rocked it
love you rocked it blows up really well
it happened now like that's true what
did it happen dating okay the
deal-breakers deal-breakers are not a
there's no post marriage deal braces
yeah that's right whatever happens after
marriage you you say words
and you lock it is sort of breaking the
bond in marriage whatever ended up in
your truth once you say those words of a
commitment it's like the spirits come
together buck and lock it in you know
it's true you didn't even talk about
this car
what up all my positive people I want to
hear your thoughts put it in the
comments below because if you're
negative shut the hell up and go drink
some raid please but if you're very
positive leave it in the comments below
for the last video over here